returning is kingpin uh i'm curious did
you consider it a different iteration of
the character with a different backstory
or do you look at it as a continuation
of the wilson fisk that we already know
i think it's definitely a continuation
like there's no difference to me there's
the physical strength that's different
the fact that he can take more kind of
violent abuse you know physical abuse
is different but
i'm you know it's very clear with the
was very clear with the writers and the
producers and the directors that
that i'm continuing the same
man that was in the
series a few years ago in daredevil so
his emotional life
he he operates through the pain of his
childhood
that's how he operates and he still does
it doesn't matter whether he's enjoying
himself or if he's having a tough time
in life whatever's going on in any scene
he's always
it's always coming through events that
happened when he was a kid and so that's
the same character to me and you know we
definitely knew that i definitely knew
that this was after the blip in that
and that he's had less power than he did
and he wanted his city back for them for
hoffman that's the way i approached it
so yeah
i think in my mind i don't know how they
think about it at marvel overall but in
my mind i think that it's they connect
as many dots as they can in the canon
stuff and
with the canon state of mind and
and some docs are possible to connect
but uh most are easy to connect and i
think that's what they try and do i
definitely have to ask you about that
ending scene in the finale with maya
um kind of that final confrontation
because i think
unfortunately it leaves a little bit up
in the up in the air in terms of the
fate of your character when you were
approached to reprise the role was it
indicated to you that hawkeye was only
the beginning of kingpin being back in
the mcu you know it only put personally
i can comment personally i can't comment
about any kind of facts because
you they just don't tell me so it made
me hope that it would continue and it
still makes me feel that way
i mean in my mind he's definitely she
definitely shot him and you know i look
i walked away from daredevil
thinking that you know at first i
thought maybe it'll come back somehow
and then very quickly after that i
thought i was walking away for good you
know so
i had always hoped because of the fans
wanted it back and everybody i'd always
hope that it would come back so i feel
the same way now i think that's actually
all the time that i have but i will say
you know there is an echo spin-off
that's been announced i'm sure you're
aware so that feels kind of like a good
opportunity to see a little more of
wilson fisk in the future i think it
would be great i remember the the comic
run it was one of my favorites of the
father-daughter relationship between
maya and him i would love the
opportunity to do that
um well it was great to see you return
and thank you so much for taking the
time to sit and chat i really appreciate
your time
you're welcome thanks happy holidays to
you you too thank you
you